بطاعه جديده واعده فلا تقمم احتضنتها
الرياض في حراك الدبلوماسيه يهدف الى
اعاده التوازن الجيوستراتيجي للمنطقه من
خلال فتح نوافذ لتحقيق شراكه خليجيه عربيه
مع الصين مستقله وقائمه على المصالح
المشتركه
القمم ثلاث السعوديه الصينيه والخليجيه
الصينيه والعربيه الصينيه انتهت بنتائج
اكدت على اهميه تعزيز التعاون والحوار
المشترك بين السعوديه والصين والخليج
والدول العربيه
وتصدرتها قضايا الامن والاقتصاد بالمنطقه
ابرز مركزت عليه البيانات الختاميه للقمم
الثلاث مواجهه التحديات العالميه وضمان
الطابع السلمي للبرنامج النووي الايراني
وكذلك ادانه الهجمات الحوثيه على الاهداف
المدنيه في السعوديه والامارات بالاضافه
الى التمسك بمفاهيم الامن
قمم وصفت بالحدث المفصلي في تاريخ
العلاقات الصينيه العربيه فيما اعتبر
محللون ان التعاون العربي الصيني لن يكون
على حساب التعاون مع امريكا
لان التعاون مع بكين يركز بشكل كبير على
الجوانب الاقتصاديه والتكنولوجيه
والتنمويه وهذا بعيد عما تتشاركه الدول
العربيه
وهذا بعيد عما تتشاركه الدول العربيه مع
الولايات المتحده في ما يتعلق بالجوانب
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه في الشرق الاوسط